hallo mein name ist luca und nicht
beantworte heute die meisten suchten
fragen über mich auf google hat mir drei
so kärtchen vorbereitet also ich würde
sagen wir fangen direkt an
die erste karte handelt von dem
suchbegriff ist luca ist luca einlauf
ich hasse euch halter also ich bin ein
meter 93 groß und wiege 83 kilo also ich
glaube das ist mehr oder weniger
durchschnitt aber mein ziel sind auf
jeden fall so 90 kilo also eigentlich
bin ich ja quasi schon genug ist luca
toni ich glaube ich lebe noch ist luke
haben mit juden zu sammeln ja ich will
und ich sind seit fast 14 monaten
zusammen wir sind zusammengekommen am
ersten juni 2018 und sind auch jetzt
immer noch zusammen genieße auto copy
frage ist ist luca millionär
das ist so crazy was leute über mich
googeln oder wissen wollen ja ich bin
billionaire und die letzte auto complete
frage auf diesen sette ist ist luca ein
mädchen
ich glaube mich also das sehen wir die
erste karte mit fünf auto complete
fragen die ich jetzt beantwortet habe
wie bereits gesagt dass wir die ganzen
sachen rausgesucht und hat sich zum
glück auch die bastelarbeit gemacht um
hier
diese ganzen klebestreifen drauf zu
packen und da schon dass das ganze video
hier inspiriert ist von der weltserie
die sich daher absolute stars einladen
die dann diese fragen beantworten aber
ich bin halt einfach enorm hat das ist
auf jeden fall die nächste karte mit dem
auto complete satz hat luca und das
erste ist hat luca eine freundin ja wie
gerade schon gesagt ich bin mit jule
zusammen seit dem ersten sechs 2018 also
ja ich bin vergeben die nächste frage
ist hat lukas capture luca hat slapshot
aber luca nutzt selbst nicht mehr so
häufig seitdem instagram gefühlt jede
funktion von snapshot kopiert hat nutze
ich dazu nur noch instagram aber ich
heiße laser luca auf cnet runter auf
instagram m ihr könnt mir gerne in die
kommentare schreiben habe ich mal wieder
aktive aus hettstedt werden sollte
hörst du dir ist ja luca hat tatsächlich
studiert auch wenn er oft nicht so
wirkte er studiert ich habe marketing
management an der fachhochschule köln
studiert und habe dort vor eineinhalb
jahren erfolgreichen meinen bachelor
abschluss gemacht
also ja ich habe tatsächlich ein
bisschen was in der birne die vorletzte
frage ist was hat sich luca für ein auto
okay das ist ein interessante frage dass
mein allererstes autobahn mini cooper
cabrio den hatte ich mit achtzehn und
den fand ich so gut dass ich mit zwei
jahre später einfach das neue modell
davon gekauft habe also wieder ein mini
cooper cabrio aber die frage ist ja was
hat lukas ein auto also was fahre ich
gerade für ein auto und ich habe jetzt
seit eineinhalb jahren einen porsche 911
targa 4 gts und bin sehr sehr zufrieden
letzte frage auf dem zettel hat luca ist
wie viel geld hat lukas und das sind ja
alles für materielle fragen ich bin ein
mensch der private informationen lieber
bedeckt halten will also beispielsweise
infos über familie wohnort oder
beispielsweise jetzt hier auch meine
einnahmen beziehen also mein vermögen
es gibt auf jeden fall viele youtuber
die ihre youtube einnahmen hier auf
youtube in dem video schon offen gelegt
haben
aber ich selbst weiß nicht was da der
sinn brandes ich kann mich auf jeden
fall sagen dass ich sehr gut von dem
geld leben kann dass ich hier durch
youtube et cetera verdiene aber genau
richtig auf das thema nicht eingehen und
ich glaube das verstehen auch wieder
dass man nicht jetzt unbedingt über
seinen verdienst treten will aber wir
machen weiter mit dem dritten und
letzten kärtchen luca super deutsch auf
jeden fall luca die gerade schon gesagt
willst du meine genaue adresse aus
gründen die er glaubt nachvollziehbar
nicht hier im video veröffentlichen aber
ich wohne noch in köln
ziehe aber in einem halben jahr nach
hamburg wo ist luca gerade in köln und
entnimmt gerade ein video auf woher
kommt luca luka
schon immer in köln gewesen sondern luca
ist geborenen bielefeld in einem vorort
von bielefeld und seine eltern wohnen
doch immer da und es ist sehr schön dort
wo gibt es die luca pizza ok interessant
jetzt gerade gibt es die luga pitzer
tatsächlich nirgendwo denn von venlo
kapitza 1 gab es ja nur 100000 stück und
von der pizza 2 gab es ja auch mal eine
millionen stück die sind beide komplett
ausverkauft leider aber wir sitzen
gerade schon in der planung an einer low
kapitza 3 und die kommt denke ich auch
noch dieses jahr also dann wird auf
jeden fall den kapitza wiedergeben in
supermärkten wurde jetzt auch schon die
letzte frage habt das macht echt mega
viel spaß
wo ist lukas niveau okay war dahin im
mülleimer an der stelle mich dass heute
geht jetzt auch beenden meiner liebe
freunde ich habe letztens einfach total
viele videos vorgeschlagen bekommen von
diesem wild auto complete interview die
das mit zu kompletten mega weltstars
gemacht haben die dann diese kerzen
hatten und das abgezogen haben und dann
die fragen beantwortet haben und ich
fand das mega cool anzuschauen deswegen
dachte ich mir hey vielleicht ist auch
cool wenn ihr euch das bei mir anschauen
habt ihr bock dass ich davon eventuell
demnächst einen zweiten teil hochladen
könnt ihr ja gerne mal ein paar fragen
und in die kommentare schreiben dann
mache ich so ein kommentare faq mit
diesen kärtchen weil es eigentlich nicht
ganz neu ist muss ich nur juli nochmal
reden dass sie das nochmal alles
zusammen basteln aber gut freund ich
hoffe das video heute war irgendwie
unterhalten aber vielleicht noch
informativ für den ein oder anderen
abonniert gern main kanal falls noch
kein luxus sein und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]